[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER 1: Cloud
migration is top of mind
for many organizations today.
While moving to the cloud
can be full of challenges,
the cloud offers many advantages
around increased agility,
new and innovative services,
and on-demand pricing
that traditional data
centers don't offer.
So let's talk about one way
to make migration easier--
hosting your applications in
a native VM VMware environment
right in Google Cloud.
Google Cloud VMware
Engine is built
to address the
biggest issues that
prevent most workloads
from moving to the cloud--
lack of resources and the
cost of re-architecting apps.
With a Google Cloud
VMware Engine,
you can migrate your apps with
no changes to your processes
because you run
your applications
on native VMware VMs in a
dedicated and private SDDC.
This means you can use the same
tools, processes, and policies
while still getting
the advantages of being
in the cloud, all
on top of deeper
integration with other
Google Cloud services.
And it doesn't take long
to spin up an environment.
You can quickly lower your
total cost of ownership
and spend more time planning how
to re-architect down the road.
Let's walk through a demo of how
to set up Google Cloud VMware
Environment with
just a few clicks.
After clicking the
Navigation menu,
we'll scroll down to
the Compute section
and click VMware Engine, which
takes us to an Overview page.
The Overview provides you
with additional details
about the service and allows you
to perform common operations,
like launching the
vSphere client,
creating a private cloud, and
adding and managing users.
We'll create a private cloud
by clicking the Create Private
Cloud button, then entering
a name for our new cloud.
We'll stick with US
East for the location
and keep the node count at
the minimum number of three.
We'll input the CIDR range
for our management appliances,
then click Review and Create.
While our private
cloud is being created,
let's talk about pricing,
which is per node
and includes all the
storage, compute,
and licensing to run
your VMware environment.
You'll pay monthly by
default, but you can also
sign up for one- or three-year
plans to reduce costs.
After our private
cloud is created,
we can access it from
the Resources screen,
which is where you can view and
manage all your private clouds.
We'll click our
new private cloud
to view the
configuration details.
This is where you can view a
summary of your cloud details,
including which versions
of vSphere, NSX-T, and HTX
you're currently using.
The links in the upper
right of the screen
allow you to launch the
virtual center client, which
is the standard
enterprise virtual center
client VMware users know
today, and expand your cloud
by adding nodes.
There are also
additional options
at the bottom of the screen that
let you remove nodes, delete
your cloud, and elevate
your vSphere privileges,
an important feature that gives
you admin access in vCenter
so you can make
the configuration
changes necessary to run
certain third party software.
Let's scroll back up to
the top of the screen
and launch our vSphere client.
After logging in, you
can see that we're
working with the same
vSphere interface that's
so familiar to admins.
This native access to VMware
provides you a standard way
to control your
applications while still
getting all the benefits
of running on Google Cloud.
Now let's return to the
Management Console page
and take a look at
the networking details
and configuration options.
This is where you can
view your firewall
tables and your subnets,
create a public IP
with just a single click,
setup and manage VPN gateways,
configure and manage
your DNS profiles,
and create and manage private
connections to Google services.
The Activities interface
provides important details
for your security
and operations teams,
including environment alerts,
details about past events,
and any currently running
tasks and their status.
Your team can also audit logs
of any activities performed
by users.
The Account screen provides a
summary of your entire VMware
Engine environment, including
all your private clouds,
and lets you subscribe
to email alerts
and add distribution lists.
The Account screen is also where
you can manage any users that
have access to the environment.
One really nice feature
of the VMware Engine
is the native integration
into Google services.
All the billing
related to the service
is integrated seamlessly into
the online account management
system, which allows you to see
all the usage of your VMware
Engine dedicated nodes right
in line with your other Google
Cloud services.
With this quick
tour, we've shown you
how to quickly generate
a private, native VMware
environment on Google Cloud
and use all the same tools
and processes you're
already familiar with.
The environment is fully
supported by VMware
and gives you the
ability to create
hybrid apps that
integrate seamlessly
with Google Cloud services.
Google Cloud VMware Engine
is available for you
to try out now.
So check out the documentation
to learn more details
and spin up your own
private VMware environment.
[MUSIC PLAYING]